when tracing crimes israel's military
has committed against palestinians
it can be difficult to know where to
begin
a timeline of subjugation that began in
1948 the atrocities numerous the
suffering ongoing
home demolitions and forced displacement
have become routine
[Applause]
endless checkpoints to restrict and
control movement where palestinians
routinely experience abuse and
humiliation
dehumanization that pales in comparison
only to the massacres perpetrated time
after time
palestinian-american journalist shireen
abu aklee's targeted killing
is only the latest in a long history of
civilian deaths at the hands of israeli
occupiers
[Music]
blood is just as much on the hands of
the united states and the european union
and great britain
and others canada as well who
stand in the way of accountability and
arm and support the israeli occupation
that
murdered shirina barackley as it
murders palestinians almost daily
the number of palestinian civilians
caught in israeli crosshairs seems
endless
but some cases stand out
in september of 2000 twelve-year-old
muhammad al-dura was shot and killed in
gaza
video of his father jamal trying to
shield his son from israeli bullets
became one of the most powerful images
of the second in the father
in 2017 an israeli sniper shot and
killed ibrahim aburaya during protests
against the u.s move to name jerusalem
as israel's capital the wheelchair-bound
activist lost both his legs in an
israeli air raid in 2008
in 2018 israeli forces killed
palestinian nurse razano najar
as she tried to help a wounded protester
she became one of the more than 100
people killed during demonstrations
against the grinding israeli blockade of
gaza
successive generations of palestinian
leaders have turned to the international
community for help but decades of
appeals have not slowed the pace of
israeli abuses what is your message
going to be to israel what is the united
states message to israel regarding the
situation in this show our message and
the ambassador gave that message very
strongly to everyone is that this has to
be investigated uh it has to be
investigated transparently and we're
encouraging both sides to participate in
that investigation so that we can get
down to the
to why this happened our highest
priority is the protection of american
citizens and the protection of
journalists it is so important that
journalists be allowed uh to do their
jobs without fear and so our message
again is let's get to the bottom of this
let's ensure this never happens again
[Music]
despite the public rhetoric the u.s
government israel's main ally continues
to send billions of dollars in military
aid to israel
emboldening what rights groups describe
as an apartheid state with devastating
consequences for generations of
palestinians
zain basravi al-jazeera